So I know last class was quite
theoretical. It was kind of on the
mathier side. So I hope people like math
enjoyed that. Today the lecture's going
to be a bit more on the economic side.
So a little less math. I mean there'll
be some algebra, but it's a little more
applied, a little more practical. So
today we're going to talk about cartels.
And I think it's helpful to start with
some examples. So the classic example of
a cartel would be OPEC.
OPEC is the Organization of Petroleum
Exporting Countries.
And what OPEC does is they get together
and they try to coordinate the
production of oil to ensure that oil
prices are high and therefore that all
these countries can
make more money. So the general idea of
the cartels we're going to look at
today, maybe I'll say the goal
There's many different kinds of cartels.
So I'm going to talk about the goal of
these specific kinds of cartels.
It's generally to coordinate
on lower production
in order to raise market prices.
Do people know any other
examples of cartels that maybe you've
come across
in uh
in your experience or in other econ
classes?
Or just things you've heard of?
Any ideas?
Yeah? I've heard of drug cartels. Drug
cartels, great great example.
So
uh drug cartels are uh
often
maybe interact a little bit differently,
but they're certainly drug cartels are
interested in
controlling uh what's on the market and
controlling how much revenue they get.
Often drug cartels maybe operate maybe
the way that they limit production or
limit competition is often they segment
the market. So it's common for one drug
cartel to say operate in the north of a
country, another cartel to operate in
the south of the country, and they have
this agreement that only one cartel is
going to produce in one side of the
country, and the only the other cartel
will produce in the other side. And
that's one way of reducing production
because you only have one side selling
in each market. Yes. What if a new comes
in?
Right. That can often lead to to
violence, right? And even with without
new groups coming in, there's often a
fight over turf. So I like to use this
example. This is a good example of a
cartel. It's not really going to fit in
with our models because our models
aren't going to have the threat of
violence. So I think this is an
important economic question, how
criminal organizations use violence to
sustain cooperation, but we're going to
think of cartels that threaten to
produce more of the good, not to kill
the other cartel. So this has violence,
which will not really be covered in our
models, but it's it's a great example of
a cartel. Other other examples of
cartels that people have come across?
>> [snorts]
>> So there's a famous one
famous vitamin cartel in the US. These
producers of it's maybe not the sexiest
industry, but these
firms that produced various vitamins,
they colluded to try to keep prices low.
I think they also split up exactly which
vitamins they each produced.
Um one that I think maybe people don't
think of as much that I think is a
a nice example is actually
the production of doctors.
So I don't know if any of you are
applying to med school, the
number of slots in the entering classes
at med schools is very restricted.
Medical schools cannot enroll more
students than they've agreed to with
various organizations like the AMA. Why
do you think
doctors have reached this agreement that
med schools cannot enroll too many
students in the United States? Why might
they want to do that? Yeah?
Exactly. So it's exactly the same idea.
OPEC wants to under produce oil so that
the price of oil is high.
How do we produce doctors?
Doctors are also something that we
produce and sell. I mean it's a bit
weird to think about selling your labor,
selling, but that's what's happening.
Well, the production of doctors is med
school. And if medical schools reduce
the number of doctors they produce, then
the price you can sell a doctor for,
that is the wage that doctors get, will
be higher. And that's exactly
what we see here. And classical guilds
also fall into this. Maybe some people
would say that the structure of PhD
programs also fits into kind of an
academic cartel. And
then maybe one last example I'll give
that also doesn't quite fit with our
model today
is actually the Quebec maple syrup
cartel.
Uh
probably not well known to people. This
one is different because this is a
government sponsored cartel. So the
government of Quebec and the government
of Canada explicitly uh
allow this cartel because they think
that
uh
producing maple syrup is a valuable uh
cultural practice in Canada and they
want to sustain the profits and the
revenues of producers of of maple syrup.
But because this is
is explicit
it's contractual, it has explicit
government support, this also won't
really fit within our models today.
So we're going to fit think about models
that have no violence and also no
explicit government endorsement. So
they're kind of these are implicit
cartels. And I'll say more about what
that means.
So the goal of these cartels is to
coordinate on lower production in order
to raise the market prices. What is the
challenge?
If you win
suppose you're an oil producing nation,
you get together with the other oil
producers and you propose a plan. We're
each going to produce less in order to
keep the market price high. That sounds
great. Everyone does better. The prices
are high, that's good for everyone.
What's the challenge here? Why might
this not be so easy? Yeah?
Defectors. And and and how might they
defect? Uh they start selling like more
than they agreed to cuz the price is
high, so they make like more profit.
Exactly right. So collectively this is
good for us, but the problem is that
each firm or each country will have an
individual incentive to deviate by
overproducing. So the challenge is that
there's an individual
incentive
to overproduce.
And we can frame this actually in the
classical economic language of
externalities. If a single firm
unilaterally deviates and overproduces
they impose an externality on the other
firms. What is the externality that I
impose on the other firms if I produce
more?
How do I affect the other firms when I
produce more?
Yeah? Your increased production leads to
lower prices on what they sell.
Exactly. So when I raise my production,
I only internalize the effect it has on
my profits, but I'm actually hurting the
other members of the cartel because by
overproducing I'm lowering the market
price and other people feel that.
So this is a classic issue of
uh people don't internalize their
externalities and they overproduce. You
can go back to pollution or
uh congestion on roads. All these
classical externality questions, this is
what's going on.
So what's the solution from the I don't
want to say solution from a socially
efficient standpoint, but a solution
from the cartel standpoint?
So I don't use solution with necessarily
positive connotation.
Well, there's a few solutions. One is to
threaten violence, but we're not going
to talk about that today.
One is to write contracts.
What we can say is we're going to write
a contract that this is exactly how much
oil you have to produce or this is
exactly how many units of vitamins
you're allowed to produce.
But in often we don't see contracts
written like this. Do you know why? Why
do we not see contracts as the solution
to this kind of problem? I think there's
a few reasons.
Yeah? I think it's totally frowned upon
cuz
when making a cartel like usually the
government would want like to enforce
like some kind of fair competition.
Right. So it's not only frowned upon,
it's illegal, right? It's very frowned
upon.
So in a domestic context, I think
there's two reasons we don't see this.
So maybe I'll say but
Maybe I'll start a new board here.
But what's the issue?
Well, within a country
this is often illegal.
I mean it depends on the country, but
certainly in the United States, if two
firms get together and they were to
write a contract that says
we're only going to produce this much
that would go against antitrust
regulations and they'd they'd get sued.
Uh
What about but I think there's a
slightly different reason. What about
across countries?
So what about OPEC?
It's not necessarily legal if if Iran
and Saudi Arabia
sign a contract
it's not really clear what court would
uh
say that they were violating antitrust
law.
But I think there's another problem. So
why is it hard for countries to to write
contracts with each other?
Uh let's see. Yeah, I think Is it like
an enforcement issue? Yeah, so say more
about that. Um like you have a contract
like the only way that you can enforce
it is like through your own oil
production, but like there's like no one
you can like snitch on and say that like
they overproduced. Okay, so I think
you're getting at two things. One is I
think what you're getting at is kind of
observability that maybe it's hard to
see who's overproduced. I guess I was
putting at but I but your word
enforcement I like I think one basic
question is who enforces contracts
between countries? Right? If there's two
firms in the US and they write a
contract and someone breaches the
contract, they can go to court in the
US. If Iran and Saudi Arabia a contract,
well, who do they go to, right? It's not
clear who can enforce that contract. So,
across countries
uh it's not clear how we enforce
contracts.
Um
kind of no enforcement mechanism.
No enforcement, maybe I'll say through
courts.
So, in both the domestic context where
collusion as a cartel is illegal and the
international context where enforcing
contracts between countries is
challenging because we don't really have
a court to enforce them,
our initial solution of writing
contracts becomes a challenge.
And because of that, what we often turn
to
are implicit cartels.
So, by an implicit cartel, I mean we're
not writing down a contract that says,
"If you produce this much, this is what
happens." But, we're
going to try to arrange our our behavior
in such a way that if someone were to
overproduce, they would be punished.
Maybe by the other firms producing more
as well to punish them.
The problem is
we have to make sure
that this is self-enforcing.
So,
but it must be
maybe I'll say self-enforcing.
So, the idea is we don't have an
external court to to take you to jail if
you violate it, but now, well, if
someone overproduces, then they're going
to be punished by another firm. But,
then we have to make sure is that other
firm going to want to actually punish
them? Are they going to want to
overproduce? And then we might need
someone to punish them and so on. So,
what we want
is exactly a Nash equilibrium. In the
absence of courts and contracts, we want
this agreement to be self-enforcing in
the sense that no one can profitably
deviate from this. So, what if we reduce
the problem to? Well, this is precisely
a repeated game between strategic
players, and we want to try to
understand the Nash equilibria or the
subgame perfect Nash equilibrium of this
game because that will precisely
describe what can be achieved through a
self-enforcing
um interaction.
All right. So, today we're going to look
at
a model of this, which is going to be
repeated Cournot competition.
So, formally, the model today is going
to be infinitely
repeated
Cournot. Remember, Cournot refers to
quantity competition.
You can think about a very abstract
cartel, but I think this is a pretty
good model for OPEC. So, so keep that in
mind as you're running example as we go
over this.
And we want to formally examine the
issues we've brought up. We want to see
let's we want to formalize this
intuitive idea that firms will have an
incentive to deviate and overproduce.
And then we're going to see how we can
try to dampen that incentive through uh
future threats to to punish by
overproduction. So, let's uh
let's get into that.
So, what's the model?
The model in each period is just going
to be standard standard Cournot quantity
competition. So, let's say we have firms
I equals 1 through N.
And we have periods
well, 0 1 2 3 and so on.
Again, there's no natural point in time
when OPEC
breaks down. Maybe eventually we run out
of oil, but you know, we don't know
exactly when that is. So, I think the
infinite horizon model is a pretty good
model for that.
And
to simplify things, we're going to
assume that each firm has constant
marginal cost production.
So,
C
where we have 0 C less than 1.
This is one point one stylization of the
model. In OPEC, not all the firms are
probably symmetric, right? Uh some
countries have uh better resources to
produce oil. They can produce oil more
cheaply. You could extend the model to
an asymmetric model, but to keep things
simple, we're going to imagine that each
of the firms involved has the same
marginal cost.
And then, demand is going to be as we
always say,
the standard demand model we'll write uh
P of Q
equals the max
of 1 minus Q and 0.
Remember here, P of Q is the market
price that's faced by all the firms. So,
this would be the market price for oil.
The market price for oil depends on the
quantity of oil that's on the market.
And it's decreasing in the quantity of
oil on the market. The more oil is on
the market and is produced, the lower
the price is. The price can never go
negative, so that's why we have the max
with zero. So, if tons of oil is
produced, well, there was a time
recently actually where where the price
of oil got negative, but uh it was only
a little bit negative uh because no one
wanted to store it during COVID, but uh
in general, the price of oil is
generally not going to be negative. And
you know, how do we interpret this one?
I mean, one should be like whatever the
total amount of oil that could possibly
produced in the in the world is. So, uh
one is a very big amount of oil. We're
just changing our units to make that one
unit of oil.
And Q uh remember is going to be Q1
plus QN. So, we're going to use the
notation from before that little Qs
refer to how much is produced by a
single firm.
The big Q is the total amount produced
by all the firms together. So, the total
amount produced is the sum of the
amounts produced by each of the N firms.
Uh and then we're going to use standard
uh discounting. So, everyone's going to
have the same discount factor
delta.
So, what that means,
maybe let's
try to write this out formally.
So, what I want to write down now using
this discount factor is let's suppose
that this is the sequence of production
levels.
Now, there's no subscripts here. So,
what Q superscript zero means is the
vector of quantities produced in period
zero. So, remember, superscripts are
always about time and subscripts are
always about the firm. If there's no
subscript, this should be interpreted as
a vector that tells me how much every
firm produced in period zero.
Then Q1 is another vector that tells me
how much every firm produced in period
one.
And I want to compute here what is firm
I's average discounted profit if this is
the sequence of production levels.
Well, it's going to be a summation.
We're going to use 1 minus delta up
front like we always do so that we look
at average discounted profits instead of
just the sum of discounted profits.
And then we're going to take a sum over
all the periods.
So, from T equals 0 to infinity.
And then, we're going to have delta to
the T
times the profit that firm I makes in
period T.
So, times pi I.
Maybe this is little pi I and this is
big pi I. I don't know if you can really
tell the difference.
And here we're going to have QT.
Remember, what is QT?
QT is Q1T
up to QNT. It specifies how much each
firm produces in period T.
So,
we can now say what is a firm's average
discounted profit from a sequence of
production decisions. We can express it
like this, but we still have to fill in
what the per period profit is.
So, let's
recall where in general
pi I of
Q1T
up to QNT
is what?
Well, this says, "In period T, what does
firm I get?" Well, they're get We need
to as usual keep track of what is their
profit per unit and then how many units
do they produce?
So, the number of units they produce is
QIT,
right? In the Tth period, firm I is
producing QIT units.
And their profit is going to be that
number of units times the profit they're
getting per unit, right?
So, what is the
profit per unit here?
Yeah. Well, we have to get the price by
summing all the quantities at this time.
Exactly. And then uh use the quantity to
get Exactly right. So, that's going to
be P of
Q1T.
Try to write small here. Up to QNT. This
is the sum of the quantities that are
produced at time T. So, that's the
market quantity. That's the amount in
the market. That determines the market
price P. But, of course, that's not all
profit for me cuz I also have to pay a
cost of production. So, we subtract C
here.
So, now we've
formalized the game.
I guess one final assumption we have to
keep track of is remember, whenever
we've studied infinitely repeated games,
we've assumed that past actions are
observed. And in this context, that may
be a strong assumption. This goes to a
question we had. Remember, we're going
to maintain the assumption. So, I'll say
maintained assumption.
Past actions are observed, which in this
case, past actions are just quantities
produced.
Do you think this is a good assumption
in this model or or not?
Yeah.
Yeah, I think it's
not great, not terrible. It depends on
the context. Uh sometimes we might be
able to see how much people are
producing. Sometimes it may be a bit
hard. And if you read when OPEC has
disagreements, this is always what
happens, right? One country says, "Oh,
you definitely overproduce." They say,
"Oh, no, it wasn't me. I" And and you'll
see cartels, I mean, if you watch
Breaking Bad, this is often the story.
People are trying to sort of secretly
sell their product without other without
other members of the cartel observing
that they're selling it.
Um and I think maybe a better model of
this would be that we observe noisy
signals of how much people have
produced. Because really what we observe
is the price. And what happens with OPEC
is they see the market price has
dropped. Everyone sees that. And that
suggests that someone has overproduced.
The hard thing is to figure out who it
was who overproduced. And that's an
exciting topic, kind of getting some
more modern research ideas, what we do
when we only have imperfect monitoring
of past quantities. Unfortunately, it's
mathematically a lot harder, so we won't
cover it in this class, but if you
continue studying game theory, I think
that's a really interesting topic. What
happens if we see price has gone is
really low, and we're trying to figure
out who it was who did the
overproduction, and we don't really know
who it is.
But we'll maintain that assumption
today.
Uh Okay. So, before we get into actually
solving for a subgame perfect Nash
equilibrium of this game, let's try to
just think about this basic challenge of
each firm having an incentive to
overproduce. So, let's just first think
of the static uh let's just first look
at the stage game.
And let's see if we can remember uh the
stage game has unique Nash equilibrium
that we solved for. I think this is a
good thing to keep in mind, maybe for
exams.
Uh the stage game Nash equilibrium maybe
I'll say was Q1
equals QN. Remember, now we're just
thinking of the stage game, so let's
just think about everyone's choosing how
much to produce.
And everyone produced maybe what I'll
call QNE.
This is the Nash equilibrium quantity,
so this is a number.
And that number turned out to be 1 - C
over N + 1.
So, it turned out that in equilibrium
the amount that everyone produced, well,
it depends on how many firms there are.
The more firms there are in the market,
the less each firm produces.
And the higher the cost C of production,
And what that meant was the market price
PNE
was what?
Well, it's 1 minus the total quantity.
So, maybe let's keep track of this. What
is QNE?
So, I told you what each individual firm
produces. QNE is the aggregate quantity
produced. Well, that's just the sum of
the amounts that the individual firms
produce, right? So, I have 1 - C over N
+ 1 summed over the N firms. What is
that? That's just N over N + 1
times 1 - C.
I've just multiplied this individual
production level by the total number of
firms N.
And once we see that, we can see the
market price PNE is going to be 1 - QNE.
Which is
1 minus
N over N + 1
times 1 - C.
And there's sort of a nice
just to help us understand this, it's
kind of a convenient
algebra trick.
Uh let's
add C and subtract C. So, if we do that,
I'll add C to the front.
And now I'm going to subtract C later
on, so we get 1 minus C
minus N over N + 1 1 minus C.
So, all I've done is I've put in a C
here,
and I've subtracted a C here.
So, I haven't done anything.
But now we can simplify things a lot,
because I have 1 minus C minus N over N
+ 1 times 1 minus C. So, if I factor out
the 1 minus C, I get C plus
1 minus C over N + 1.
And I think this is a bit
more easily interpretable. Can people
someone to give an interpretation for
this market price here?
So, how much is each firm charging in
this equilibrium?
Maybe I'll just go They're charging
well, their cost plus a markup, right?
So, this is the classic markup term.
This tells me that that each firm is
making positive profits, right? Because
each firm is producing a positive
amount, and the price they're getting is
strictly higher than the cost of
production. So, that means their profit
per unit is strictly positive, and the
scale of the markup is decreasing in the
number of firms. The more firms there
are, the smaller this markup is.
Okay.
And now, let's just compute one last
thing,
which is what is pi NE?
So, what is the profit
that each firm makes in this
equilibrium?
Well, each firm is producing 1 minus C
over N + 1,
and their profit per unit is exactly the
markup, which is 1 minus C over N + 1.
So, it turns out this is 1 minus C
over N + 1 squared.
Okay. So, that's the the Nash
equilibrium.
Now, the question is, how could they do
better in the stage game?
So, I'll ask, can firms
do better than the Nash equilibrium?
This may not be a a Nash equilibrium,
but I'm just saying is there another way
they could produce to do better than in
the Nash equilibrium?
And the idea, so let's say, suppose the
firms wanted to make the sum of all
their profits as high as possible. What
would they do? So, let's be a bit more
specific. How could they do better?
Well, what they could do is maximize
the sum of their profits.
How would you do this? How would the
firms maximize the sum of their profits?
Yes? If you choose exactly one firm to
produce everything, and the rest is in
that case N is one, so then the market
can be higher.
That's right. Um so, I think you're
getting very close, yeah. Uh they they
want to think about So, so if only one
firm produced, how much would What would
be the the right amount for that firm to
produce?
Then that firm would produce 1 minus C
over 2. Right. Exactly. And we can
actually There's a few different ways we
can achieve that. So, the key is
if we want to maximize the sum of our
profits, what we want to do, and this is
what you described as a special case of
this, we want to collectively act as a
monopolist. We want to make sure that
the sum of the amounts we produce is
exactly the amount that a monopolist
would produce, because we know that a
monopolist maximizes profits.
So, to maximize the sum of the profits,
what we need is we need Q1
plus QN
to equal the quantity that maximizes the
sum of the profits. It turns out that's
exactly the monopoly quantity.
So, we want this to be the monopoly
quantity.
Why is this? Well, the trick is, if I
produce Q1,
and firm two produces Q2, all the way up
to firm N producing QN, the sum of the
firms' profits is exactly the same as
the profit that a single firm would make
if they produced Q1 all the way up to QN
by themselves.
And the way that we maximize that amount
is exactly by setting it equal to the
monopoly quantity, which in this example
is
1 minus C over 2.
So, what you described is one special
case of this, where one firm could
produce the monopoly quantity, and
everyone else could produce zero. But I
don't think that would be a very
effective cartel. If I said, "Hey, other
countries, I want you all to produce
zero, and I'm going to produce
everything." Uh I don't think those
other countries would be very happy,
right? So, probably we would split it a
bit differently. A natural split would
be an even split, where each of us
produces 1 minus C over 2N.
So, one thing we could do, so e.g.,
we could do Q1, I'll go down here,
the even split
would be we each produce
maybe what I'll call QM. So, before I
described the
Nash equilibrium quantity, now I'm going
to describe When I say monopoly
quantity, what I really mean is each
firm's share of the monopoly quantity.
So, this is
1 minus C over 2N.
So, QM is
technically 1/N of the monopoly
quantity, because it's the quantity that
each firm needs to produce to ensure
that the total production is equal to
the monopoly quantity.
Okay. Now, if we compare
these two numbers,
uh what do you see? Which is bigger, and
what's your intuition for that?
Yes, let's assume N is uh at least one,
at least two.
So, which one is bigger, and why?
Yeah. The Nash equilibrium is larger, um
and the intuition for that could be that
in order to do better than Nash
equilibrium,
the firms kind of need to
have a closer collaboration to kind of
maximize as if they were a
single firm. Whereas, each of them in
that non-Nash equilibrium state, the
monopolist state, would be kind of
incentivized to produce more to to
capture profit.
Exactly right. So, this is exactly what
we talked about at the beginning.
In the Nash equilibrium, the firms are
behaving optimally given the way
everyone else is behaving, but that
actually turns out that collectively it
hurts them because they're producing too
much.
They would actually do better if they
each produced less.
If they each produced less, then the
market price is going to be higher.
And the the payoff of each firm is
actually going to be strictly higher.
The problem is this will not be an
equilibrium. And what will happen is
suppose we did this. Let's just check.
This is not going to be a Nash
equilibrium. And why yeah, what is the
deviation for say firm I? What would
they
How could they do better? Would they
want to increase or decrease their
production?
Increase their production, right? So
it's not a Nash equilibrium because firm
I
prefers
to strictly
increase production.
And we can check that mathematically,
but let's just This seems a little
puzzling now. And this is getting at a
core game theory idea. We said that
these production levels maximize the sum
of everyone's profits.
But now I'm saying one firm can do
better by strictly increasing how much
they produce. So how is that consistent?
I thought we were already maximizing
profits. So how can one firm do better
by deviating?
Uh yeah, in the front. You're maximizing
the sum. It's it
Exactly. So what must happen? If this
firm produces strictly more, this firm's
doing better, but what do we know must
also happen?
The other one's doing worse. In fact,
the amount by which they're doing worse
more than offsets the amount that this
firm's doing better. So I benefit
myself, I hurt everyone else. On
average, we're the sum of payoffs goes
down because I hurt everyone else more
than I help myself, but I don't care
because I'm helping myself. That's the
basic intuition of this.
All right. So now the question is can we
sustain
the monopoly levels in an equilibrium?
So
question is
Here's my question.
So we're all better off if every period
we produce QM rather than QNE. That
would be great for us.
It's not clear though how we can sustain
this in a self-enforcing way because we
already said if we try to do this, one
firm can strictly benefit by deviating
and producing slightly more.
So how can we do this? Well, what's the
idea?
We need some way to punish people for
overproduction. And in fact, we'll just
punish them if they produce anything
other than what they're supposed to.
Really, overproduction is the is the the
tempting thing to do. But here's the
idea. We want to punish
firms for overproduction.
So any ideas about
how we might be able to do this?
So we're getting together. We see that
one firm has deviated. Say they've
produced too much. Now what might we
want to do to try to punish them?
Yeah. We can all move to the Nash
equilibrium quantities. Exactly. So I
think the first I was
That's exactly where we're going. I was
expecting a different answer, so well
done. You you jumped ahead. What I was
expecting people to say is we would just
flood the market, right? The problem
with that is that may not be
self-enforcing because why does the firm
actually want to flood the market? So
indeed, what you're suggesting, I mean
we could think about doing that later.
But indeed, the natural thing to do is
the way we could punish is we could
revert to the Nash equilibrium. Remember
last class when we talked about the folk
theorem, we described these strategies
where if anyone deviated, we reverted to
the Nash equilibrium. In this case,
so by reverting
to QNE.
So what this says is we're going to try
to produce the monopoly level. We're
each going to produce a small amount.
We're going to get high profits because
the price is very high. If we observe
anyone deviating, well now we're all
going to produce the Nash equilibrium
level. We're all worse off, but we're
actually willing to carry out this
punishment because this is itself a Nash
equilibrium. That's the idea. And now we
want to formally check this.
Uh I guess first question, will this
always work?
What are we going to need for this to to
work for this to be a Nash a subgame
perfect Nash equilibrium?
What's going to need to be true about
delta?
Yeah. It needs to be sufficiently large
enough that we kind of value the profits
in the
Yeah, exactly. So I guess, I mean we'll
formally check this, but it's always
good to kind of make a guess in advance.
Our guess is that this will work
if delta is high enough.
Right? Because the idea is I can benefit
today by overproducing. The only reason
I'm not going to do that is I'm afraid
of this punishment in the future, but I
have to be patient enough that I care
about that future. If I only care about
profits today, then of course it's not
going to be a Nash equilibrium because
all I care about is the benefit that I
get today.
Okay, so now we're going to actually
construct this equilibrium. So let's
start
So now let's uh
construct
the SPNE
that has this form.
Uh it's going to be helpful to define
two functions
just because if we don't define these,
the algebra gets really complicated. So
let's just make two definitions.
f of Q
and g of Q.
So for any quantity level Q, f of Q is
going to say if we all produce Q, what
is our path?
So mathematically, this is
Q
times 1 minus nQ minus c.
And technically, this only makes sense
if Q is less than 1 over n so that this
number doesn't so prices don't become
negative. So this says if we all produce
Q,
the market price is going to be 1 minus
nQ because nQ is the market quantity. So
1 minus nQ is the market price. And if
we subtract c from that, we get the
profit per unit and then we multiply it
by Q.
Uh and then the other thing we want to
understand is
how well can a firm do
if everyone else is playing Q and I
choose my best deviation in the stage
game.
This is going to be the key deviation we
have to worry about, so we want to have
notation for this. So this is going to
say what happens if I
choose my quantity level Q prime to
maximize my profit given that all the
other firms are choosing Q.
Well, if I choose Q prime, this is how
much I produce.
What is the price going to be?
Well, it's going to be 1 minus n minus 1
Q minus Q prime and then I subtract c.
So here, the price is 1 minus the total
quantity on the market. The total
quantity in the market is what's
produced by everyone else, which is Q
times n minus 1 cuz there's n minus 1
other firms. They're each producing Q.
If I choose Q prime,
then this gives me the total amount
produced. This gives me the price and
then I subtract my cost.
Uh and if we we could actually
do a little algebra.
Uh I don't expect people to see this,
but
I think it's actually going to be this.
It's not The formula doesn't really
matter, but this is what it'll be.
Okay.
But we'll just stick with these these
two formulas here.
All right. And then what is our strategy
profile?
Well, it's exactly what we said.
So one,
each firm
produces Q
M
until a deviation.
But two, if anyone has deviated,
every firm
produces
QNE.
So this is just formally writing down
the Nash reversion idea that we said. We
start by producing QM every period. If
as long as no one's deviated, that's
what we do. But if any firm deviates,
then we all revert to the Nash
equilibrium quantities QNE.
So now we want to check that this is a
subgame perfect Nash equilibrium.
As usual, we're going to use the
one-shot deviation principle. And we're
going to check every history and check
that no firm has a profitable one-shot
deviation. But we're going to use a
different representation of this
strategy called an automaton, which is
going to turn out to be very useful for
kind of construction the way we think
about these equilibria. So let's look at
what's called the automaton
representation.
Automaton
So you recall that when we described
these strategies, the way we analyzed
them is we often grouped all the
histories into two buckets. We said
they're the histories where someone's
deviated and the histories where no
one's deviated.
And the automaton representation
formalizes that in terms of states.
We think of, you know, what's the
current state that we're in and how do
we behave in that state? So, let me just
write it down.
To represent this equilibrium, we're
going to need two states.
We'll call it the monopoly state
and the stage game Nash equilibrium
state.
And now we need to specify how we behave
in each state. Well, in the monopoly
state, we each produce the monopoly
price a monopoly quantity, sorry. That's
easy. So, QI equals QM for all I.
And in the Nash equilibrium state,
we each produce
the Nash equilibrium quantity. That's
pretty easy.
So, what do I really mean by these
states? Well, they're kind of this
mental construct.
But, let's just describe how things work
and then and then we can maybe interpret
it. So, the idea is we start in this
state. Initially, we're each going to
produce QM. So, I'm going to put an
arrow here to say this is the state that
we start in.
And in this state, what we're supposed
to do is we're each supposed to produce
the monopoly quantity.
Okay?
Uh
Now, what we have to describe
is how we transition between states.
So,
the idea of this equilibrium is we're
going to stay in this state as long as
no one has deviated.
But, if someone deviates, then we move
to a different state.
So, what I'll write
is I'll write an arrow here
to say we're in state M and we stay in
state M if what? If QI
equals QM
for all I.
That's the only way we're going to stay
in this state.
Otherwise, someone has deviated and then
we move to the other state.
So, I'll write otherwise here.
If we're in this state,
well,
once someone's deviated and we're in
this state, we actually stay in this
state forever. There's no way to leave
this state. So, we're just going to put
an arrow here that says, you know,
anything.
So, this simple graph actually fully
describes a strategy and in fact fully
describes the strategy profile in this
equilibrium. And I think the way I like
to visualize it, I mean, of course, if
firms were actually colluding today,
they'd use computers, they'd keep track
of things. But, a very simple way to
think about this is
all I need to do is have like two
positions on my desk, the monopoly
position and the Nash equilibrium
position. And I like to imagine I just
have a stone. And I start by putting the
stone in the monopoly position. I look
at my desk, I see and every firm is
doing the same thing. We start within
the monopoly position.
We all say, "What do we do here?" We all
produce the monopoly level. Then
tomorrow, we observe what everyone
produced yesterday and then we
potentially move the stone from the
monopoly position to the Nash
equilibrium position if we observe that
someone has deviated.
If no one deviates, we keep the stone
there. And then tomorrow, we see where
the stone is and we decide how to play.
So, this is a very simple representation
of the strategy profile.
Okay. So, now
come over here
and let's write down the conditions
for equilibrium in this game.
So, it turns out the key to analyzing
uh equilibrium using this automaton
representation is to write down what
we'll call the value
function.
And in this case, we need to specify the
value function each of the two states.
So, we're going to have VM
and VNE.
And what the value function says is,
"Suppose in the first case, suppose
we're in state M today
and everyone follows this strategy.
What is the average discounted payoff of
the firms going to be?"
And then VNE says, "Well, if we're in
state NE and we all follow that
strategy, what is the average discounted
payoff of each firm going to be?"
So, let's start with
M. If we're in state M,
it's a symmetric equilibrium, so we're
just going to write down one firm's
payoffs. All the other firms are going
to be the same. If we're in state M and
we all follow the strategy, what is the
expected
discounted average payoff of each firm?
Well, first let's see what happens. If
we're in M,
well, today
we all produce the monopoly quantity.
We stay in M. Tomorrow, we all produce
the monopoly quantity, we stay in M. The
next day, we all produce the monopoly
quantity. So, we're going to get the
monopoly quantity every single period.
And what is the payoff from that?
The average discounted payoff from that?
Well, it's just
F
of QM.
F of Q is a function that tells me what
is my payoff if we all produce quantity
Q.
So, if we all produce quantity QM, this
is exactly my payoff.
What about
VNE?
Well, here it's going to be F
QNE. This is what uh my average
discounted payoff from here on if we're
in state in this state.
So, now we're going to use the value
functions to write down the equilibrium
conditions.
And when we use an automaton
representation, we have one equilibrium
condition for every state.
So, we're going to have state M
and we have state NE.
And what our equilibrium condition says
is, "If we're in state in this Let's
take this condition. If we're in state
M,
then each firm is better off continuing
with their equilibrium strategy than
choosing the best possible one-shot
deviation."
So, each
equilibrium is going to have the
following form.
In state M, we need to check that if I
do what I'm supposed to, well, by
definition,
I get my payoff VM. That's what it means
if we continue with the equilibrium
strategy in state M.
And we have to compare that to the best
possible payoff I could get from a
one-shot deviation.
And then we'll do the same in NE. Here
we are today. This is what I'll get if I
follow the equilibrium strategy. And on
the right-hand side, we want to say,
"What is the best possible payoff I
could get from a one-shot deviation?"
So, let's start.
Uh I think maybe
this one is easier.
Uh Oh, no, we can start with M, it's
fine. So, what is the best possible
If I'm going to deviate, how should I
deviate when I'm the when we're in state
M? Yeah? You're doing that with your
strategy.
Exactly right. So, if I'm going to
deviate at all, I know I'm going to be
punished. I'm going to be punished in
exactly the same way no matter how I
deviate. So, I might as well choose the
deviation that gives me the highest
payoff today, right? And that's exactly
and my payoff from that is exactly given
by this function G. So, the best
possible deviation, well, today I'm
going to get G of
QM.
Remember, this doesn't mean I'm playing
This means if everyone else is playing
QM and I choose the quantity Q prime
that maximizes my flow payoff,
this is the payoff I'm going to get.
And then if I do that, what state are we
going to be in tomorrow?
Well, we're in this state, I deviate,
which means we move to the Nash
equilibrium state.
So, from tomorrow onward,
we're going to be in the Nash
equilibrium state, so my payoff is going
to be VNE. But, the only thing we're
missing is discounting, right? Remember,
with average discounted payoffs, how
much weight do I put on what I get today
and how much weight do I put on the
infinite future?
Well, we know we always put, you know, 1
minus delta today and delta in the
future, right? So, we're going to have 1
minus delta here
plus delta VNE.
And it's really important that we
interpret this correctly.
The first term is, "What's the payoff I
get today if I choose this optimal
deviation?"
This term is not saying, "What's my
payoff tomorrow?" This is incorporating
my payoff tomorrow, the next day, the
next day, the next day. But, by our
definition of VNE,
we've defined VNE to say, "What is my
payoff from today onwards once I'm in
state NE?" And that's exactly what we're
going to measure
on this side. So, this is reflect It's a
little tricky because in this case it
happens to agree with my flow payoff.
But, it's just important to understand
that this is representing
everything from tomorrow onward. It's
not just representing what happens
tomorrow.
Because what I do today affects
everything from tomorrow onward.
Okay? And now let's go to VNE.
We're going to have a similar formula.
What's our formula going to be down down
here?
Well,
I have the same optimal deviation. If
I'm going to deviate, I might as well do
uh the best thing. Uh
So,
it's a little tricky in this case.
Um
Yeah, so maybe
Here it's actually a little tricky
because
my best deviation since we're in a Nash
equilibrium is actually to do what I'm
supposed to do. And then
but
it actually doesn't matter here cuz
we're going to stay in NE anyway.
Um
So,
let's see.
Uh
Maybe this case we should just
Yeah, I feel like this equation is
misleading. Let's just It's true, but
let's just say
I'll just say best deviation.
But, my claim is that this is never
profitable.
Uh because if we're in the Nash
equilibrium state today,
whatever we do today, it can't be any
better than playing the Nash equilibrium
action, and it has no effect on what
happens tomorrow. Uh yeah. I'm a little
confused. Is it somehow you define the
value function is just equal to F?
And as I understand, F is just my payoff
today. Uh great great point. That is
very confusing. I Yeah, I see where
you're going.
It happens to agree with F, but that's
simply because we're using average
discounted payoffs. So, maybe what I
should write
is
uh
1 minus delta
times
F of QM.
Let me Good good point. Uh plus delta F
of QM.
Plus dot dot dot. That's really what I
mean.
Good point. Um but so, if I want to
compute what happens, I'm starting in M.
I'm going to get F of QM today. I'm
going to get F of QM tomorrow and so on.
I'm going to discount, and I'm going to
take the average.
It turns out that that equals
F of QM by the way we defined it. So,
you're right. It's tricky in this case
cuz it happens to reduce to this, but
this is the interpretation of where
that's coming from. Uh and that reduces
to this. Is that Is that clear? Yeah,
great. Thanks. Thanks for I should have
written it that way the first time.
And of course, the same applies here.
Hm? Yes. In Nash equilibrium, you just
said VNE is greater than best deviation
ever profitable. Is that just by
definition that we are in a Nash
equilibrium?
Um
it's a little trickier than that, so
I'm hesitant to write. Maybe I should go
back and write it the other way. What's
tricky is
um
>> [clears throat]
>> It's It's the fact that we're in a Nash
equilibrium, and that tomorrow we're
going to be
we're going to be in the same state no
matter what. So, maybe
let me write it out more formally. So,
what we need to show
So, in the first case, I can use this
function G to simplify my life. Here,
it's a little trickier. So, really what
I need is it's greater than
pi I
QI prime
Yeah, let me write it this way. And
actually, the first one we could write
this way, but it reduces. So,
I'm firm I.
What I could do instead of following my
equilibrium strategy is I could instead
produce QI prime today.
If I produce QI prime today, and
everyone else is producing the Nash
equilibrium amount, then this is my flow
payoff today,
and we multiply that by 1 minus delta.
Whatever I do today,
we're going to stay in the state Nash
equilibrium, because if we look at the
arrows here,
whatever I do, the arrow brings us back
to the Nash equilibrium state. So, we're
going to be get delta Nash equilibrium
tomorrow.
Uh
and how do we see that this is less than
or equal to this?
Well,
whatever QI prime I choose, it can't
give me a higher flow payoff than
choosing the Nash equilibrium quantity,
because that's the definition of a best
response.
So, we see that this is less than or
equal to 1 minus delta
uh
F of QNE
plus delta VNE
and that's exactly
VNE.
So,
how do we see that this right-hand side
is smaller than what we want? Well, all
I've done is I've compared the flow
payoff to the Nash equilibrium payoff.
Whatever quantity I choose, it can't be
as good. It's no better than playing my
best response, which is exactly the Nash
equilibrium quantity, and that gives me
these payoffs.
Uh and then
I
substitute in this over here, and we're
going to get this.
Any questions on it?
So, the action is going to be here.
Right? We want to check that star is
satisfied,
uh and let's
plug things in and and see what we get.
Okay, so let's look at star.
Well, we have our inequality star, and
we have our values for the Vs on the
left side. So, we're just going to
substitute these values in to our
inequality over here and see what we
get. So, VM becomes F of QM,
and that needs to be greater than or
equal to
1 minus delta
G of QM
plus delta
times VNE, which we look over here,
that's F of QNE.
And here, I think we can really capture
exactly the idea of the temptation of
the deviation.
If I don't deviate, I get F of QM
forever after.
If I do deviate, I get a maybe a higher
number today
because I increase my flow payoff today,
but then forever after, I get a lower
number.
So, let's note
that
G of QM
is strictly greater
than F of QM,
which is in turn strictly greater than F
of QNE.
So, this is what I'm supposed to get. If
I deviate, I bump up my payoff to this
today,
but then I drop down to this forever
after.
And we want to make sure that I'm
patient enough that the drop down
forever after offsets or sufficiently
offsets the potential gain today.
Any questions?
Um
So, now
let's just do some algebra.
Let's
bring
Should we want to
bring everything to this side, I think.
So,
uh what we're going to have is delta
I want to bring everything involving
delta to the left side, and everything
not involving delta to the right side.
So, I have minus delta G of QM. I'll
bring that to the left side, and that
becomes plus.
Then I have plus delta F of QNE. I'll
subtract that and bring it to this side.
So, I get minus
F of QNE
greater than or equal to
So, now let me just divide,
and I just get delta greater than or
equal to
this threshold, maybe delta upper bar,
which is defined to equal
G of QM minus F of QM.
And I sometimes think it's easier to
decompose it this way.
So, this is G of
>> [clears throat]
>> Okay.
So, as we expected, this is going to be
a subgame perfect Nash equilibrium if
delta is large enough, if the players
are patient enough.
And let's try to interpret the uh
the payoffs over here.
Well, what I want to think is
I want to think that this gap
represents my one-shot gain from
deviating, right?
But this gap
This is sort of my gain today
from deviating, and this is kind of my
loss forever after.
Maybe we'll call this G equals gain, and
this loss equals L, right?
So, we're supposed to be playing the
monopoly quantity every period. If I
deviate, I can overproduce. I do
strictly better today. I gain G for
myself,
but forever after, instead of getting
the monopoly quantity, we all produce
the Nash equilibrium quantity, which is
strictly worse. So, we lose this this
amount L.
And it turns out, if you just look at
the algebra I've done here,
g of qm minus f of qm, that's exactly
the gain. So, we get g over here.
And in the bottom, we exactly have the
gain plus the loss.
And this is kind of a a general formula
uh that says
what's the requirement on delta?
It has to be large enough roughly that
the potential one period gain I get is
offset by the eventual loss I
experience.
So, let's make sure we understand how
this how this varies with g and l. Let
me ask this. So, if g gets bigger,
what happens to delta bar?
Let's start with l, that's the easier
one. If l gets bigger, what happens?
Yeah?
Okay, but yeah, let's let's um so, this
is just algebra. Let's just you can
check on your own. Let's just look at
this and and this this formula over
here. Just g over g plus l. Yeah. If the
loss gets bigger, delta has to be
smaller. Delta bar gets smaller, right?
And what is that? So, can we interpret
that? As the loss gets bigger, delta bar
gets smaller. So, what's the It just
means that you have to put more value or
put less value on the future if you're
going to be gaining more in the future.
Right. So, it's easier to just stay in
equilibrium, right? If the loss gets
larger, that means the punishment is
very powerful.
If I get caught for deviating, tomorrow
I experience this huge loss. If I
experience a huge loss for deviating,
it's not very attractive for me to
deviate. Therefore, it's easier to
sustain the equilibrium because if delta
bar is smaller, that means I don't have
to be as patient for this to be an
equilibrium.
If l is really, really big and the
punishment is really, really bad, even
if I'm pretty impatient, this still
constitutes an equilibrium because the
the punishment is so severe.
So, more delta satisfy this
even smaller deltas, more impatient
deltas, when l is very large.
What about g? Can we also reason through
g?
This is a little trickier cuz g is on
the top and the bottom, but it is
increasing in g. Maybe it's not quite so
easy to see, but uh it is. Uh so, why is
this increasing in g?
Yeah? Well, if you're able to gain more
than the threshold for deciding that you
shouldn't deviate, wouldn't it need to
be higher?
Right. If I can gain a lot today,
it's going to be really, really tempting
for me to deviate. So, it's going to be
harder to sustain the equilibrium, and
that's only going to work if the players
are really, really, really patient. So,
this threshold gets higher, meaning
fewer deltas satisfy it because
the temptation to deviate gets really,
really big.
And you can check that, you know,
everything's in terms of f and g, but
remember at at the end of the day, f and
g involve n. So, let's just see if we
can get some intuition for this.
Well, maybe this is too hard to see, but
it turns out that delta bar,
you can check, is increasing in n.
So, can we give kind of an economic
story? What What does this tell us?
What we might expect about which cartels
are successful and which cartels are not
successful based on this fact? Smaller
cartels.
Smaller cartels meaning meaning what?
Yeah, you're right, but Like the ones
that have like less players involved.
Fewer firms, right? If the the players
themselves are big, so we have to be
careful about what small means. The
players are bigger, but the the number
of players is smaller, right? So, as n
gets bigger,
we have to be really, really patient to
sustain cartel behavior.
And given that people aren't necessarily
that patient,
that may not work out. So, we we would
expect that cartels might be more
successful and last longer when n is
small and we just have a few big players
interacting. And indeed, that's pretty
consistent with the empirical evidence
that it's hard for many, many firms to
collap- to coordinate and work together
and sustain cartel behavior.
Even when there's few firms, things do
break down. So, you know, this may seem
like kind of
you know, just a math story. We have the
Nash equilibrium, we have monopoly, but
this is actually exactly what happened
in in the 1980s, right? Um Saudi Arabia
got frustrated that everyone else was
overproducing a little bit, and they
flooded the market, and the price of oil
dropped dramatically. So, we see exactly
this kind of punishment. Saudi Arabia
said, "Look, I'm I'm tired of all these
other countries overproducing relative
to what they're supposed to." And they
punished everyone by flooding the market
and uh the price dropped. And
you know, this had huge effects
globally.
Okay, let's do one more
equilibrium construction that I think
just kind of
um
illustrates things. So, let's do a final
equilibrium. So, before we did a Nash
reversion equilibrium, now we're going
to do what's called
a carrot and stick equilibrium.
And
what was distinctive about this
equilibrium is once someone deviated, we
reverted to Nash equilibrium forever
after.
But if you look at what happened with
Saudi Arabia, they didn't just produce a
high amount of oil forever. They flooded
the market for a few years, and then
they eventually brought their production
down again, and prices went up again.
So, what we often see in these cartels
is punishments of limited duration.
Someone overproduces, we punish them for
a year or two or a month or two or
whatever, and then we get back to the
good thing that we are doing because
ultimately that's what we want to do.
So, the question is, can we have these
carrot and stick strategies? And the way
this is going to work is we're going to
have two production levels, qc less than
qs.
So, carrot and stick are kind of generic
terms for carrot is a reward and stick
is a punishment, right? This is like I
guess animals or pets, right? You give
them a carrot or you I mean, it's kind
of violent, but anyway, uh that's what
it is.
Uh
so, okay, I'll use this Maybe I
shouldn't use this terminology, but uh
I'm I'm I've inherited this terminology.
I'll use it. Um
So,
we have the carrot is the low production
level. This is the the good thing that
we like.
The stick is the high production level.
So, this could be the Nash equilibrium
and the monopoly, but it doesn't have to
be. It's just general production levels.
And the idea is we're going to start
with the carrot.
And if someone deviates, we're all going
to produce the stick level but only for
one period. Then if everyone does what
they're supposed to, we come back to the
carrot level.
So, let's try to represent this on as an
automaton.
So, let me erase this automaton and get
a new one.
So, now our automaton is going to have
two states, the carrot state and the
stick state.
So, c
and s.
And we're going to start in the carrot
state.
And in the carrot state, everyone
produces this low level c, which is
good.
And in the stick state, everyone
produces this high level
qs, uh which is not so good for for
everyone.
And now we have to say what happens. I
think in this case, the transitions are
a little more complicated. So, in the
carrot state, we're going to stay in the
carrot state if everyone produces the
carrot level.
So, we have an arrow here if what? If qi
equals qc for all i.
If everyone does what they're supposed
to, we stay here.
Otherwise,
we go to the stick state.
But now,
this is where it gets a little tricky.
Let's see. Can someone Can we figure out
what happens in the stick state?
What happens if we're in the stick state
and everyone produces the stick
quantity? What state do we move to? Do
we stay or do we move?
We
We move back, right? Cuz now, if
everyone does what they're supposed to,
okay, we did our punishment, we're now
ready to get back to where we were
before. So, now we're going to have this
arrow if
qi
equals qs
for all i.
And then, what happens if someone
doesn't play the stick?
What do we do?
Well, then we stay in the stick state
and punish them again tomorrow. Right?
So, at first this may look confusing,
but I think the way to interpret is in
either state, if you do what if everyone
does what they're supposed to, we move
to the carrot state tomorrow.
That's this arrow and this arrow.
If anyone does what they're not supposed
to, we go to the stick state tomorrow.
That's this arrow and this arrow. And
that's true whether we're in the carrot
state today or the stick state today.
Either way, we go to the stick state
tomorrow.
Um I should say when I write otherwise,
it can be a bit ambiguous.
Otherwise is referring to the source of
the node. So, in the c state, think of
we're in the state, look at all the
arrows. We can either do this, or
otherwise we do this. And then
similarly, if I'm in the stick state, if
we do this, we go here, and otherwise we
go here. But when you just see all the
otherwise, you might think what are they
referring to? They're referring to the
the state we're in, the source of all
the arrows.
Okay, so now I don't want to do tons of
algebra,
but I just want to see if we can set up
the value function and the equilibrium
conditions for this equilibrium, and
then on the problem set you'll get to
actually do all the algebra. But I think
here we'll see the benefits of this
value function approach. So,
So, there's two steps always.
On the left side, we compute the value
functions as we did above.
On the right side, we write out the
equilibrium conditions.
And
if one of these is the Nash equilibrium
level, it's a little tricky. So, maybe
just to simplify my life, let's assume
that
these are not equal to qne.
So, the carrot and the stick are both
different from the Nash equilibrium
level.
Just it avoids this kind of issue we got
up before where the best deviation is
not a deviation and let's just um
let's just not worry about that.
Um
Okay. Now, I want us to conceptually
understand what's happening here.
The left-hand side is nothing to do with
equilibrium. The left-hand side is just
saying
if this is the strategy we were to play,
what would everyone's payoffs be in each
state?
Then, using that information, we go to
the right side which is saying, is it
actually an equilibrium for people to
play this way?
But, notice we can ask, what would my
payoff be in each state if this is the
strategy we play? I can ask that
question whether or not that strategy is
actually an equilibrium.
So, let's try to write down our value
function formulas here.
So, we have V
C
and VS.
So, we have a carrot state and a stick
state.
And we want to compute, remember the
interpretation is the average discounted
payoff from today onward if we're in
this state.
So, let's say we're in the C state. What
is our payoff going to be today if we
all follow the C state? We can use the
same notation that was up here.
Well, it's F of QC.
And we'll multiply that by 1 minus
delta.
And then, if we follow F of QC
what happens tomorrow? What state are we
in?
We're still in the carrot state, right?
So, now we get delta
V of C.
Now, this is the one that's a bit
trickier.
If we're in the stick state
today we get
1 minus delta F of QS.
But, then what do we get on the
right-hand side here?
Yeah.
Is it delta
VC?
Exactly. Because if we do what we're
supposed to do today, we end up in the
carrot state the following period.
So, this is saying, what is my average
discounted payoff from today onward in
the stick state? Well, it's the payoff I
get today plus
delta, we've got a discount, times my
average discounted payoff from tomorrow
onwards. Yes. So, value function is
assuming that you follow the strategy
profile. Exactly. So, that's the key
thing over here. We're not saying about
equilibrium, we're not talking about
deviations, we're just saying, given the
strategy profile, let's compute the
value functions in each state.
Um
Now, in general, you can see we're going
to have a system of equations with and
however many states there are, call it
N. No, that's number of players.
T uh K, if there's K states so, I'll
write this down here. If there's K
states in general
we have K equations and K unknowns.
Because we have to specify the value in
each state and we have a formula for
each of these. So, we get K states
and K unknowns.
And as you know this is going to be a
linear system and it turns out it will
actually always have a solution. That's
something that's a math result you can
you can show. So, this is always a way
that we can compute what the values are
going to be in each state.
Notice that this is kind of there's
something very clever going on because
if I just started in one state
let's suppose I didn't use this approach
and I just wanted to say
let's say we had a really complicated
let's say we had 10 states, okay? And I
wanted to say, what is my payoff
starting in this state? Well, I have to
keep going through it. I'd say, well, I
do this today, then I go to this state,
then I do this tomorrow, I go to this
state, I go to this state, I go to this
state. You might think I'd have to
compute the whole infinite horizon of
all the different states I could pass
through.
What's kind of magical about this
approach is we've just reduced all these
computations to a single system of
linear equations, which is much easier
to solve. I don't have to explicitly
compute my entire path through the
automaton, I just have to solve the
system of equations. And this is related
to some kind of nice math. Yeah. So,
each unknown
corresponds to basically a one-to-one
correspondence between states.
Exactly. So, formally you can think of V
as a value function that's defined on
the domain of the set of states. So, a
function needs to specify a number for
every state and that's precisely the
value we get starting in that state.
Uh and if we solve this, we can pretty
easily solve this first equation just to
make sure this makes sense, right? If we
subtract delta VC from the right side
then we get 1 minus delta VC
equals 1 minus delta F of QC.
So, that tells us that VC equals F of
QC. Does that seem right?
Yeah, because if we're in state C, we
never leave.
So, every period we get F of QC and
that's our average discounted payoff.
Question? Yeah. I mean, because we know
we stay there for VC, we know we stay in
state C if we do it the first time.
There have been any like mathematically
you get the same answer without having
to find instead of writing 1 minus
delta? You're right. This you could have
just jumped right You're saying you can
basically see what the payoff is going
to be here. Yeah, but you put delta V
delta times F of QC.
You could have you you could have yeah.
But, it's down here where the benefit
comes in because here and more generally
if you know, what happens tomorrow
depends on a third state and then, you
know, so this is the general approach
that always works, but you're right. In
this case, if we're in what's called an
absorbing state, once we're there, we
never leave, it's pretty easy to
calculate what happens. We don't need to
worry about what happens in any other
state. But, when we have transitions
between the states, then it becomes uh
trickier. But, yeah, exactly.
Um but, this will never give you the
wrong answer. Um yeah.
Okay. So, now let's write down our
equilibrium conditions. Once again, we
have a condition
for each state. But, remember, we're
actually capturing a lot here because in
each state, there are a lot of different
one-shot deviations we could use. So,
what what when we say equilibrium
condition, what we really mean is we're
saying in each state, we want to check
that there's no that no one-shot
deviation is profitable. And the way we
can check that is to check that the best
one-shot deviation is not profitable.
Because if the best deviation is not
profitable, then none of the deviations
is profitable. There may be some really
bad deviations, we don't care about
those, we only care about the most
attractive deviations. And that's
exactly what we're going to put in here.
So, in the carrot state, we need VC
greater than equal to something and VS
greater than equal to something.
Eventually, we'll substitute things in,
but I want to just do it conceptually
this way.
So, in the carrot state
once again
if we deviate
we're going to get punished. And the
punishment we experience doesn't depend
on the way in which we deviate. So, we
might as well choose the deviation that
maximizes our flow payoff today.
And what is our flow payoff going to be
if we choose the deviation that
maximizes our flow payoff? We have a
function for this, right? It's G of QC.
Okay.
So, this says, if I choose the best
deviation today, this is what I get
today. If I deviate, what state are we
going to be in tomorrow?
Yeah. Stick.
Yeah, exactly. So, now we're going to
get
VS over here.
Okay. And now I think this is the
hardest one and we'll we'll we'll stop
stop here. Now, we're in the stick
state.
We're going to choose our best deviation
in the stick state.
Again, I'm only allowed to write it this
way because the punishment I experience
doesn't depend on exactly which quantity
I deviate to.
If the if the deviation I chose affected
the punishment, then we'd have to it
would be things would be a lot more
complicated. But, all we have to ask is,
am I deviating or not? However I
deviate, it's treated the same way in
the future, so I might as well choose
the deviation that maximizes my flow
payoff.
Uh
and then
what do we get
on the right-hand side?
Delta times what? What happens if I
deviate?
VS again, right?
So, notice when we were
defining these, we always had VC here
because we're looking at what happens if
I do what I'm When we're looking at the
equilibrium condition, we're considering
deviations on the right-hand side.
Whenever I deviate, regardless of which
state I'm in, I go
uh to the stick state.
Now
let's just understand what I think is
kind of tricky here
is this is actually capturing a lot.
If I deviate today
so, let's just understand kind of the
anatomy of my one-shot deviation.
So
we have today
tomorrow
and then thereafter.
If I deviate today to say QI prime in
the stick state
we had a really simple formula on the
right-hand side. But, what's actually
happening is pretty complicated. If I
deviate today to QI prime
and then return to my equilibrium
strategy
what am I going to produce tomorrow?
Does anyone want to guess?
Stick.
Well, tomorrow I go to the stick state.
So, I'm going to produce QS tomorrow.
And then the day after that, I'm
actually going to produce thereafter
I'm going to produce QC.
So, this one-shot deviation is actually
really complicated. I'm in the stick
state I deviate, that means I stay in
the stick state tomorrow I'm following
my equilibrium strategy in the stick
state, so I choose QS.
But if I choose QS and I'm in the stick
state, then we transition to the carrot
state the next day, and then I choose QC
the next day.
So the path of play following this
deviation, and then it's going to be QC
forever after.
Is actually really complicated.
When we wrote our formula here, things
looked much simpler.
How is this formula reflecting this
complicated path moving forward?
Yeah. I just have a question. Why are
sometimes S and C subscripts and other
times superscripts?
Uh
good point. Uh
I think I want
these to be superscripts.
Um
there's not a great reason. I often had
Q sub I here, so I made this a
superscript, but then I never have V sub
I, so I made this a subscript, but uh
everything's the same. Yeah. Also,
what's Q and pi?
That could be in either stick or carrot
state, right? Uh I'm I'm looking at this
I'm looking specifically at this case.
I'm in the stick state.
I deviate.
Because I deviate, I'm in the stick
state tomorrow, so then I follow my
strategy since it's a one-shot deviation
and choose the stick quantity. But then
the next period I'm in the quant in the
carrot state, and then I choose QC. So
my point here is that a one-shot
deviation can lead to a really
complicated path of play. The reason I
don't have to worry about it is VS is
already taking into account this future
path. So this path here of SCCC is
already reflected in the value function
VS. In fact, we can see over here VS is
precisely reflecting that I get the
stick today and then the carrot forever
after. So this is sort of showing you
the power of the value functions that I
don't really have to keep track of the
total sequence of of play. I just have
to keep track of what state I get to
tomorrow, and then it takes care of
itself.
Let me stop there. Sorry for going
slightly over, and uh good luck on the
midterm on Tuesday.